are the visionaries nominated for
achievement in cinematography
yeah
dude greg fraser
nightmare alley dan lotson
[Applause]
the power of the dog ari wegner
[Applause]
the tragedy of macbeth bruno delgado
[Music]
west side story giannis kaminsky
[Music]
and the oscar goes too
uh
nominated three times it's the most
words i ever spoke here
[Applause]
presenting is where it's at
i i bet you guys are wanting to hear
what okay uh dune greg frazier
[Music]
this is the first oscar and second
nomination for greg fraser he received
his first nomination in this category
for his work on lion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow listen i'm so happy this awards up
early so i can get out and get to the
bar but i will keep it short for that
reason
um
denis villeneux
sir master master denis
um
you know he's brought a whole group of
unknown actors together
um to make an amazing movie along with
our lovely producers thank you um
collaborators i'm nothing without this
with my my my friends patrice and paul
and
donald and
jackie and i mean
it got amazing um
my crew i'm not gonna name them all
cause it will take too long but i will
call you all straight after this um and
speaking of calling mum
i will return your call and i apologize
um lauren all the friends and family
celebrating around the world um and
melbourne and uh most importantly my
wife jody um
my children felix leo and poppy you know
allowing a middle-aged man to go out and
play with his friends in the sand dunes
for six months is pretty amazing so
thank you i'll be home in time for
dinner
thank you guys
[Music]